right drain the broccoli yes okay now
really important again from the pan okay
turn it off drain up yes back out and
when you eat broccoli you don't wanna
eat it when it's soaking wet so that's
right into that dry pan this gets rid of
any excess moisture that's the noise you
want it here garlic crusher okay we put
the pan are you putting the water okay
rocking back into the pan okay
don't leave me the singers don't cook
there get rid of that water make the
rocky nice and crisp garlic in there
crush the garlic in there okay and then
and it was a touch of olive oil and look
here it's so natural but really
important okay to take the water out
there first little toss that's it
small toss big time that's a big [ __ ]
okay now exciting part
Oh bachelor start to slice the salmon
they carefully lift that onto your board
okay get your plates times me Minami and
now no butter olive oil okay keeping me
keep with me place out I'm with you done
you'll drive so it's going to take off
the excess pastry remove that slice
there there's no stammering that's just
the outside flaps where we marked it
with a palette knife that's where we cut
straight down and look the most amazing
yeah salmon on crew is just slightly
pink in the center which is beautiful
yeah and it looks magnificent and more
importantly it's so easy to do fold that
back over there yeah now you know that
work right as I always come home you do
a little drop this now
I know passing struggling but trust me
it's not that difficult girl I love
bright and slice off your gums it don't
- hands
broccoli onto a plate yes okay
now the smell of that suited luckily
we're going yeah smell of my time then
potatoes on now haters cuz I forgot we
got no there you go most amazing some
room crew yes with garlic Saudi blocking
you potatoes done
[Applause]